I've been trying to tell y'all it's not
your circumstances or your situation
that determines if you're going to be
successful or not I've been telling you
with your mindset it's the way you see
it it's the way you sing it right and
I'm hurt man I'm hurt I'm hurt people
are hitting me up E.T man I've been
working for a year I've been working for
two years I got injured is it over with
uh E.T I I'm going through pain I'm
going listen to me very closely you got
to hear what I'm saying I've been trying
to tell you for the last two years that
pain is temporary I've been trying to
get that into your spirit I've been
trying to get you to celebrate pain are
you hearing me I'm trying to get you to
have an understanding that pain is your
friend that pain is going to take you to
the next level so the only way I can do
it is I got to keep it 100. look where I
am right now
because I wouldn't assemble the story
that my past equals my future the past
will equals your future if you live
there if you're using a rear view mirror
to guide yourself you're gonna crash
so what you've been through is horrific
what you've been through is unjust I'm
on your side
but if you hang on to it you have no
future and you have no one to blame but
yourself a lot of people give up they
surrender they run with the Tails
between their legs it's a god-ordained
opportunity there are opportunities here
in the midst of crises three types of
people gonna come out of this
millionaires
billionaires and Witnesses people who
stood around and watched you have
something special you have greatness in
you
and whatever no test no testimony
whatever is in front of you you have the
power to handle it
but I don't know what to do okay got
that you don't know what to do
figure it out you don't have to know
what to do walk by faith
not by Society
figure it out
everything that exists somebody was
willing to put in the energy and the
time
to figure it out
I want you to think about something real
quick tell me one thing one thing
in your life that is great
that came as a result of being
comfortable
because everywhere I look and everywhere
I I see in today's society everybody's
doing doing everything they can to be
more comfortable
right they're looking for the more
convenience we're looking for the
quicker they're looking for the faster
and see there's opportunity in that for
those of you that want to get better
because I'm going to tell you right now
all the great things in my life all the
great things and other high Achievers
lives all the reasons that these
successful people that you look up to
that you aspire to be like are the way
they are have all come from a place of
being uncomfortable
that's just a fact if you keep going if
you keep looking for a waiver where
there's a will there's a way if you keep
moving
if you keep falling forward if you keep
getting back up
something's gonna happen Bob Marley said
something I like he said you never know
how strong you are
until being strong
is all you have
you never know how strong you are until
being strong
it's all you have it's your only option
and you've discovered
if you don't panic if you don't run
you're discovered you are stronger than
you give yourself credit for being
don't surrender
don't give in
just keep moving forward it doesn't
matter how many times I fail I'm going
to courageously pursue it I don't care
what people say I don't care what they
think this is something that I want that
gives my life meaning and value you got
a volcano like that again somewhere free
yourself from the chains of your past
I'm not saying your past doesn't matter
but listen my mother I tell people this
all the time and it's the truth
if my mother had been the mother I
wanted to be
the mother she should have been
I would not be the man I'm proud to be
today
because I had to become a practical
psychologist right before any schooling
figure out if your parents if the people
around you said all the things you
thought they should have if they had
just not been toxic if it encouraged you
you wouldn't have any muscle and right
now you know how many muscle because
you're using that as the excuse if
you're thinking that and I'm not
attacking you brothers and sisters I'm
calling to you because I know you're
more otherwise I just keep my mouth shut
we just you've been hypnotized by a
culture of weakness yes there are people
that you don't want to hang out with
that will not serve you
but then move on don't sit there and
talk about it constantly don't waste
your time and you say but what if it's
family Tony
come on this family too and you learn to
grow you go there in my life someone can
get your goat if someone can piss you
off if someone can make you feel less
than
that's God coming to you saying grow you
need some spiritual growth there's got
to be some change in your perception
your belief your emotions your spiritual
look of life so that can't happen
anymore when things are going bad don't
get all bummed out don't get startled
don't get frustrated
no just look at the issue and say good
now I don't mean to say something trite
I'm not trying to sound like Mr Smiley
positive guy that guy ignores the hard
truth that guy thinks a positive
attitude will solve problems
it won't
but neither will dwelling on the problem
no except reality but focus on the
solution take that issue take that
setback take that problem and turn it
into something good go forward
and if you are part of a team that
attitude will spread throughout
finally if you can say the word good
guess what it means you're still alive
it means you're still breathing and if
you're still breathing
[Music]
we've got some fight left in you
get up
dust off reload recalibrate re-engage
go out on the attack I went to work and
I stayed in my room I cut the lights off
unless the student came to see me I was
listening to my music I pray like I
never prayed before I spent more time
with God more time in the world listen
to me I had pain going through I felt
sabotaged there were some people who I
felt they were out to get me are you
hearing what I'm saying they wanted me
gone you talk about haters and I went
through this for a whole year are you
hearing what I'm saying I'm talking
about sabotage I'm talking about pain
I'm talking about there was things I
didn't want to get up there was days I
didn't want to put my clothes on there
was days I didn't want to face the world
are you hearing what I'm saying but I
realized when I look back at it all what
God was telling me is you stuck on Goods
huh you got the best two jobs in your
life you got your dream job sir but this
is only the beginning this is not the
end this is not where I want you to be
for the rest of your life and so I was
blessed because I went through so much
pain that that pain they actually pushed
me ah you better hear what I'm telling
you today I'm telling you that that pay
pushed me to Prosperity that pain pushed
me to Greatness pain ain't permanent ah
you better hear what I'm telling you
your pain ain't permanent your pain
ain't permanent you can get through this
you're bigger than your pain you're
better than that and let me tell you
something when I left both of those jobs
I made up in my mind ET you gonna work
through this you gonna get up you gonna
get dressed you gonna get out and you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna do what
you've been called to do you're gonna be
what you call me you're gonna have and
you're gonna prove to everybody that
tried to break you you're gonna prove a
room everybody trying to stop you
everybody tried to kill your dream
you're gonna prove all of them wrong
failure is a massive part of being able
to be successful you have to get
comfortable with failure yet you have to
actually seek failure failure is where
all of the lessons are you know when you
go to the gym and you work out you're
actually seeking failure you want to
take your muscles to the point where you
get to failure because that's where the
the adaptation is that's where growth is
successful people fail a lot they fail a
whole lot more than they succeed but
they extract the lessons from the
failure and they use that the the energy
and they use the wisdom to come around
to the next phase of success you've got
to take a shot you have to live at the
edge of your capabilities you gotta live
where you're almost certain you're gonna
fail that's the reason for practice
practice is controlled failure you're
getting to your limit getting to your
limit getting to your limit you can't
lift that you can't do that you until
you get to the point that all of a
sudden your body makes the adjustment
and then you can do it failure uh
actually helps you to recognize the
areas where you need to evolve so fail
early fail often fail forward